didier bering secrétaire fédéral de fo
santé bonsoir ddv ring merci d'être avec
nous quelle est votre réaction ce soir
après l'adoption par le parlement de
plusieurs mesures
on regrette une réaction qui est en
demi-teinte parce que les mesures que
nous attendons aujourd'hui pour
l'hôpital sur de différends d'ordre ce
soir le parlement vient d'entériner des
recommandations qui était au départ
attendu par le ségur
ce ne sont certainement pas les plus
importants que nous attendons
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital il y a eu les
mesures annoncées par monsieur bérard
hier ou avant-hier plus exactement qui
elles ont été plus d'ordre salarial pour
pour les soignants qui qui était attendu
depuis de nombreuses semaines et nous
attendons toujours encore un geste très
très fort du gouvernement sur sur les
lits et sur les effectifs
ça veut dire qu'en gros nez mesure n'est
plus réclamer ce sont celles qui n'ont
pas été forcément retenu par le
gouvernement
très certainement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le qitâl a plus besoin
d'avoir une réflexion une politique que
très incisive par rapport à
l'augmentation du nombre de lits par
rapport au rapport à faire un travail
sur les effectifs au site pourrait
augmenter les effectifs aujourd'hui
venir parler de la gouvernance des
établissements
je pense que c'est prématuré parce qu'il
faudra que nous fassions un bilan après
la pandémie pour voir ce qui a marché ce
qui n'a pas marché et revoir peut-être
le paradigme d'en parler le président
mâcon il y a
il y a quelques mois lorsqu'il était à
mulhouse parce que ce paradigme
aujourd'hui il faudra très certainement
le changer parce qu'on me la crise de la
coved aura mis en exergue les grands
carence de l'epita important ça fait un
an malheureusement le tragique épisode
de mulhouse ça fait maintenant un mois
un an par dont un en avant le début de
cette pandémie
et pourtant pas grand chose ne semble
avoir changé comment vous vous
l'expliqué aujourd'hui certains manques
de volonté de la part du gouvernement
non je ne pense pas que c'est une
question de volonté du gouvernement je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut que l'on
retravaillé sur le modèle de l'hôpital
voilà sauf que c'est pas le moment parce
que les hospitaliers aujourd'hui sont
occupés dans la crise
ils ont la main aujourd'hui dans le soin
ils ont la tête
il est occupé à soigner la population
française qui arrivent de manière très
massive à l'hôpital et donc voilà il ne
sont pas en ce moment dans une phase de
réflexion par rapport à l'organisation
des soins et lui nous avons besoin aussi
aujourd'hui de retrouver un petit peu de
sérénité à l'hôpital au pouvoir bilan t
l'ensemble de cette séquence et d'en
tirer les bonnes mesures
une dernière question justement quelle
est la situation concrète aujourd'hui
dans vos hôpitaux en moselle alors au
moselle aujourd'hui la situation est
très disparate par rapport à la
moselle-est la moselle
voilà sur sur le secteur de metz mais
nous avons nos établissements qui sont
aussi en plan blanc nous allons nous
établissements où les personnels sont
extrêmement pas si fatiguée parce qu'ils
ont été sollicités de manière très
importante depuis maintenant 18 mois et
donc la situation est vraiment très très
compliqué pour eux pour bon nombre
d'établissements de de l'autre
département
mais je crois que ce n'est pas qu'en
moselle que c'est comme ça je crois que
sur la région parisienne s'est séparé il
ya les hauts de france tellement il y a
toute la région de marseille denisty
sont aussi en flux tendu on voit très
bien qu'aujourd'hui la situation est
vraiment préoccupante sur l'ensemble de
tout le territoire et il faut bien sûr
ajouter là dessus les dom où on sait que
la situation est si préoccupante que ça
soit sur l'île de la réunion
ou bien ou bien aussi un tout petit peu
en partie merci dd belling d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france reste